and we are just learning according to
the Reuters news agency
um that a spokesman is being quoted by
them as saying that the former Pope
Benedict has died no more information as
present and it's the Reuters news agency
that is reporting this but they are
saying that uh former Pope Benedict has
died we were of course await more
information but just to remind you of
course that Pope Benedict who's 95 years
old was the first leader of the Catholic
Church to stand down in 600 years he did
that in 2013 citing Advanced age we can
see the live pictures of the Vatican as
Reuters is reporting that former Pope
Benedict has died
we have heard updates from the current
pope as to the condition of Pope
Benedict in the last few days expressing
concern and asking people to pray for
him but according to Reuters Pope
Benedict has now indeed passed away
apologies for interrupting you and Kevin
schofields we were looking to the year
ahead there of course but I wonder if
you have any thoughts on this news that
Reuters is suggesting that Pope Benedict
has indeed passed away
yes incredibly sad as I'm speaking as a
Catholic myself and obviously is always
a very sad time when a pope dies it was
we knew sadly that this was coming for
Benedict hasn't been well for quite some
time
um but yeah it's still it's still a
shock and I'm sure the thoughts of
Catholics around the world as well as
just
um all people around the world I think
we'll be we'll be with him right now
um he had a relatively short time as
Port was quite unusual that he stood
down
um and became Pope Emeritus but um but
yeah it's a very it's a very sad
occasion
and I don't know if you remember I mean
Pope Benedict Was was 85 when he
surprised people didn't he back in 2013
with his decision to step down and that
was just eight years after he'd been
elected Pope that did take people by
surprise didn't it it wasn't something
that we'd seen
no that's right I mean if you remember
he obviously
um replaced Pope John Paul II who had
um been pulled for a very long time and
and feeling Health but you know remained
in post until his death so yeah it was
highly unusual for Pope Benedict to
decide to sit back I think it was a very
brave decision actually that he took at
the time
um but yeah um as we know you know since
then Amber says Health has been has been
failing and uh yeah we knew that this
day was obviously coming but it's still
tremendously started
yeah and I'm just saying that on Twitter
Vatican news has now tweeted and we can
see that on our screens now saying with
sorrow I inform you that Pope Emeritus
Benedict XVI passed away today at 9 34
in the Mata ecclesii Monastery in the
Vatican further information will be
provided as soon as possible